and just very quickly we have just a few
questions
here what is your advice regards the one
who is affected by Jin
and this question is common now it seems
like there isn't a family except that
they are affected by magic or by gin
possession my advice to myself first and
foremost increase in the obligatory
actions the the increase in that
increase in recitation of Quran
especially Bak
especially be always in the state of
w because the the Devils they don't like
wo say that which the prophet would say
100 times a
day 100 times a day
is a protection against the
Devils protection they don't like be
upon and that will be also a great
protection be in the D of that's a
protection in the D in the lessons of
why because you're always hearing
it you're always
hearing this great K heavy on the
scales a great k
if you say sincerely from your heart
before you die you enter
Paradise
hates so be upon and be upon
purification especially before you sleep
some people complain that they have
nightmares
say 100 times a
day sleep with W when you come to sleep
place your two Palms together and blow
the spit will blow and re
and wipe your body and repeat as far as
the hands can reach and repeat
that do it three times Subhan Allah
these are beautiful says you blow before
you recite the ks or you blow at the end
when you recite the ks and you wipe your
body uh with that see the Devils they go
inside the uh veins
inside it goes inside the vein it runs
through the blood so when you're doing
that with the Quran and you blowing on
and you're doing that and you're wiping
over yourself you weaken the Shan either
you weaken he weakens you or you weaken
the Shan it's a battle the battle is on
the fight is on you have weapons Allah's
given you use them the strength is in
returning to the DI of Allah the
strength because prop said
make sure your tongue is moist with the
of Allah so be upon the of Allah be upon
the recitation of the Quran be
upon in the evening three
times three times in the morning three
times in the evening be upon the
after and Allah will protect you the
closer you get to Allah read fat read fa
over your
pain wherever your pain is because f is
called read over your pain that you have
don't go to the
of or the one who adverti himself I'm
the curer no you're not the curer Allah
is the
curer Allah is a curer not you
if you have to go to a person if it
becomes un and you do go to a
of not somebody who charges you and rips
you off if you are cured and you give
him
something which is allowed if you are
cured says if you are cured then you
give him something
fine but these criminals out there
there's a lot of them they even touch
women on their heads and they read on
the women and they touch them Subhan
Allah this is
is
Haram and they getah taxfree money that
they cheat the people with and the
person is still sick 10 times 15 times
coming back and forth back and forth he
should be teaching you the Sunnah read
over yourself have when you read that
Allah is the curer and he can remove
this from
you before you if if it doesn't happen
if no magic happened to you from the
preventions is eat seven dates in the
morning upon an empty
stomach do and there are things that are
done by by
experience he says for
example read fa he said it helped me a
lot reading fa upon water
read on the water you drink every day
read on it hopefully if you have
hopefully it will get rid of the knots
if you have knots inside because magic
could be done by way of eating you may
eat something from a
magician may eat the magic and it will
take time to come out either you vomit
it which is one way or you eat something
so bitter that makes you vomit or that
makes it come out
he mentioned uh some of the bitter uh uh
what do you call it herbs that you can
get which will maybe help out get that
magic out or that you can read on the
water read fa over it there's no
particular Del for
this except that f is a cure and said it
helped me a lot and mentions it and that
is allowed
inshallah then do that because we've
seen as well from those who
came and we know that have come to us
and this has helped them whenever they
drink the water with f in it then it
burns the
devils and you be constant upon that
Allah subh will cure
you that's what we hope Allah will cure
you we have to be
constant the devil The Magicians can't
overcome Bak somebody
who has sporadic behavior all of a
sudden is probably due to Magic it could
be due to Magic the behav changes when
you notice that they read Quran they
become calmer again they become and they
go back to normal then alhamdulillah
with the of Allah the hearts become
content and then sometime what happens
is The Magicians they renew the magic
after a year or after some time they
renew it and then it comes back again
and the
person is overcome by
Jin or some devils the the evil gin they
overcome them to the extent that they
can even make them harm themselves kill
themselves harm themselves so this
matter is serious it's not a joke you
holding on to your Dean it is it's a
blessing from Allah to protect you from
these Devils they don't like cleanliness
be upon woodo always they like dirty
places they're like filthy things and
these magicians you'll find them praying
to these Devils naked you find them
doing evil things as we asked one who
was was affected with
magic he said we asked him what was what
did you see from the wife that did Magic
on him he said one of the things I saw
is that she when she was a magician she
was praying naked that's
Allah so these devils
they want to harm you and they do evil
filthy things in order to overcome you
but they will never able to overcome you
if Allah wills and you return to the th
of Allah and you return to the sun of
the messengeri wasallam and be war of
these uh Criminal rais Who go out there
lying to the people for a miserable gain
of the D and some of them they will read
on water the water cost 30 P actually
one pound say he gone up isn't it one
pound and they say now because I read
over it
is2 so it makes a profit of a pound say
taxfree so don't listen to these
individuals be
careful why don't you read fat on it why
do I have to give it from a re you
yourself prepare protect yourself from
these criminal Liars that
lie and if he's a person of Sunnah then
they will be doing things of the Sunnah
not lying to you